antes de empezar con la nomenclatura de
algunos al que nos vamos a ver este par
de al que nos que son muy famosos
tenemos aquí a r limoneno con la
terminación en lo que significa que es
un al que no y que tiene por lo menos un
enlace doble aunque aquí podemos ver que
tiene dos lo que hace famoso a este al
que no es que huele a naranja ok
esta molécula es la que hace que las
naranjas cuelan la naranja entonces
aunque nunca antes hayas escuchado
hablar de esta molécula seguro te has
encontrado con ella y las oliva y de
este lado tenemos al alfa pine no otra
vez con la terminación
n que indica que esta molécula tiene un
enlace doble ahora el alfa pin en no lo
podemos encontrar en la trementina que
es un solvente que se utiliza para
pintar con helio muchas personas piensan
que huele feo pero eso no es cierto si
llegas a encontrar una trementina de muy
buena calidad
este alfa pine no huele muy bien
entonces aquí tenemos dos al que nos con
muy buena
entonces vamos a ver otros ejemplos de
al que nos íbamos a nombrarlos digamos
por ejemplo que tenemos un al que no de
esta forma con un doble enlace por acá
entonces de acuerdo a la nomenclatura
iupac si tuviéramos un alka no lo que
haríamos es buscar la cadena de carbonos
más larga que podamos encontrar en esta
molécula ahora para los al que nos vamos
a hacer lo mismo pero tiene que ser la
cadena de carbonos más larga que podamos
encontrar que incluya al doble enlace
entonces nuestra cadena es ésta
por acá
y bueno aquí no importa cuál de las dos
patas escogemos y entonces contábamos
cuántos carbonos había en esa cadena 1 2
456 carbonos entonces si tuviéramos un
arcano lo que tendríamos sería un ex que
son 6 carbonos y después a n o de que es
un arcano ahora aquí tenemos este enlace
doble que hace que esta molécula sea un
el que no y cuando estamos lidiando con
al que nos las terminaciones siempre van
a hacer
n y bueno son 6 carbonos entonces lo
lógico es ponerle un prefijo de ex
nuestra molécula es un externo y ahora
vamos a enumerar a cada uno de los
carbonos pero de tal forma que la
numeración haga que este enlace doble
esté entre los números más chiquitos que
se pueda ok entonces este extremo está
más cerca del doble enlace entonces
vamos a decir que este carbono es el
carbono número uno este es el número dos
número tres número cuatro carbono número
cinco y carbono número seis si
hubiéramos empezado la numeración por
aquí este enlace doble estaría en el
carbono uno dos tres cuatro pero bueno
queremos el carbono con número más
pequeño cerca de nuestro enlace doble
entonces este enlace doble está en el
carbono número dos y por lo tanto aquí
en frente del externo vamos a poner un
guión
el número de carbono en el cual se
encuentra nuestro enlace doble pero
todavía no hemos terminado para nombrar
a esta molécula nos falta agregar estos
dos grupos funcionales por aquí que
resultan ser simplemente dos grupos met
y los que se encuentran en el carbono 4
y en el carbono 5 entonces esta molécula
es 45 dimetil dimetil 2 externo
seno ahora hay que tomar en cuenta que
yo lo estoy escribiendo así porque tome
clases con un profesor muy bueno muy
tradicional lo que se recomienda
actualmente para la anotación iupac es
poner este 2 aquí en medio del ex y del
en el nombre actual de esta molécula es
45 dimetil dimetil x
pero bueno tú tienes que checar con tu
profesor de química cuál de las dos
notaciones está siguiendo
aunque porque este tipo de notación
tiene un montón de tradición puede ser
que tu profesor esté siguiendo esta
anotación más tradicional bueno ahora
vamos con otro al que no está vez vamos
a ver un al que no cíclico y vamos a
ponerle un doble enlace por aquí bueno
aquí está nuestra molécula entonces
vamos a ponerle el nombre y para eso
tenemos que buscar la cadena de carbonos
más larga que contiene al doble enlace y
pues por la forma de esta molécula
esa cadena más larga es justo todo el
ciclo así es que como le llamamos a esta
molécula pues si esta molécula fuera un
alcano como tiene 6 carbonos esto sería
un ciclo hexano pero pues tiene este
enlace doble por aquí entonces es un al
que no y por lo tanto vamos a llamarle
ciclo externo
ok seguimos con la terminación n
que significa que tenemos un enlace
doble y que es un al que no ahora
todavía no hemos terminado por ejemplo
sería muy bueno determinar en donde se
encuentra el enlace doble pero resulta
que como es un ciclo podemos empezar a
enumerar los carbonos donde nosotros
queramos y entonces cuando hay enlaces
dobles en ciclos no tenemos que poner el
número en el cual se encuentra el enlace
doble porque siempre empezamos a
enumerar justo en el enlace doble
entonces vamos a empezar a numerar por
aquí o por acá y empezamos a enumerar
los carbonos en el enlace doble justo
para que el enlace doble esté asociado
con el número de carbono más pequeño y
bueno también este grupo metil por aquí
nos gustaría que estuviera en el carbono
más pequeño también entonces la pregunta
es cuál de estos dos puntos tiene que
ser el carbono uno así es que pues vamos
a poner una copia de esta molécula
y a este ciclo exe no lo vamos a empezar
a numerar por acá mientras que a este
ciclo exe no lo vamos a empezar a
enumerar por acá entonces si este es el
carbono número uno el carbono número dos
tiene que estar del otro extremo del
enlace doble entonces este es el número
6 así es que según esta numeración esta
molécula sería 6 metil 6 metil ciclo
externo
ciclo
pero bueno eso de que el grupo metil
esté en el carbono 6 es un número muy
grande ya me empieza a sonar a que esta
no es la forma correcta de enumerar los
carbonos de este lado tenemos por aquí
el carbono número 1
entonces el carbono número 2 tiene que
estar del otro lado del enlace doble y
entonces este es el carbono 3 carbono 4
carbono 5 y carbono 6 y entonces el
grupo metil está en el carbono número 3
por lo que esta molécula es un 3 metilo
ciclo externo y siempre queremos que el
grupo funcional esté en el número de
carbono más pequeño entonces esta es la
manera oficial de llamarle a esta
molécula y este nombre no se utiliza
entonces esta forma de enumerar los
carbonos es incorrecta bueno y ahora qué
tal que tienes toda tu molécula por aquí
pero de repente sale un grupo de esta
forma pues a este grupo funcional se le
llama vinilo be nilo y también tenemos
otro grupo funcional que se parece mucho
al grupo vinilo digamos que tenemos por
aquí nuestra molécula y de repente sale
algo de este estilo resulta que este
grupo funcional se le llama a él y lo
vamos a ver un ejemplo donde haya alguno
de estos dos grupos
así es que tenemos esta molécula la
cadena más grande de carbonos que
tenemos es este ciclo que tiene 6
carbonos entonces estamos hablando de un
ciclo externo
con la terminación n o porque tenemos
aquí el doble enlace y tenemos que
empezar a enumerar los carbonos entonces
sabemos que o este carbono o este
carbono van a ser el carbono número uno
y con la experiencia que tuvimos con el
ciclo pasado creo que todos podemos
pensar directamente que este es el
carbono número uno y entonces este es el
carbono 2
4 5 y 6 y bueno este ciclo externo
denota a toda esta cadena y ya nada más
tenemos que hablar de este sustituye
ente que podemos ver que es un vinilo y
que está en el carbono 1 esta molécula
es un 1 vinilo ciclo externo
ahora vamos a ver un ejemplo en el que
hay dos enlaces dobles y por qué no
también un halógeno como el cloro como
le vamos a llamar a esta molécula pues
tenemos que buscar la cadena más grande
de carbonos que contenía un enlace doble
entonces tenemos esta cadena que tiene 1
2 3 4 carbonos y el prefijo para 4
carbonos es put
but podemos empezar a enumerar nuestros
carbon nuevos y podemos empezar desde la
izquierda o desde la derecha ahora si
empezamos desde la izquierda tenemos 12
4 nuestros enlaces dobles están en los
carbonos 1 y 3 y el halo que no está en
el carbono 2 sin embargo si hubiéramos
empezado a numerar desde la derecha
nuestros dobles enlaces también estarían
en los carbonos 1 y 3 pero el cloro
estaría en el carbono número 3 esta es
la forma correcta de enumerar los
carbonos así es que tenemos doble enlace
en el carbono 1 y 3 y tenemos que
denotar un poco más eso de que tenemos
dos dobles enlaces entonces en lugar de
poner únicamente la terminación
n que indica que hay un enlace doble
vamos a agregarle el prefijo be que se
asocia con el 2 entonces esto de aquí
nos está diciendo que tenemos dos dobles
enlaces y bueno podríamos simplemente
dejarlo así 13 but lleno pero para que
se escuche mejor y se entienda más vamos
a ponerle una vocal por acá y la que
mejor suena es la
esta molécula se llama 13 bhutta de
lleno claro que nos falta decir que hay
un cloro en el segundo carbono y
entonces ponemos simplemente dos
cloro y listo eso hacemos con todos los
halógenos entonces tenemos cloro y bromo
yodo floro aunque es el nombre oficial
de esta molécula es 2 cloro 13 butadieno